what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to
rola tomasi on the michaela peterson
podcast before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
and if you guys have watched three or
more of my videos and you have not
subscribed we have beef okay beef
so hit that subscribe button okay so
guys guys
i have been wanting to react to this
video for a long time
a long time i'm excited okay hold on
[Music]
first of all welcome to the podcast
thank you
thanks for having me
i've wanted to talk to you for a while
because i heard about your book you know
a long time ago the rational mail i
thought it'd be interesting to talk to
you and so i invited you on last week
after people from the fresh and fit
podcast said
you guys should talk
and it wasn't actually until it was two
days later when i saw that you'd put out
a that like four hour long video on me i
always and
yeah well i thought
so i thought what we should do because i
still want to talk about your book but i
thought we should go over some of the
points in the video because
i think that there's
misrepresentation of who i am on the
internet
uh and so some of the things you talked
about in the video
were out of order and weren't quite
right
and so i wanted to go through that
and then get to your book
and i would also like to thank you for
coming on and giving me the opportunity
to do this because i really do
appreciate that
so
let's start i've got some notes here i'm
prepared i was a bit nervous
but i don't bite so
sure
okay um
this is going to be interesting this is
oh my god i'm so excited there's a part
of the video i wanted to react to and
i'm just okay
okay so in
i think it was 2019 you sent out a tweet
i believe it was 2019 sent out a tweet
and it had kind of outlined
how you and i think a number of people
on the internet perceived my life it was
long 20 000 people liked it
right um that wasn't me though that was
i didn't put that out it was a it was
somebody actually somebody linked me to
that and uh so maybe you retweeted it
well i i didn't even i don't think i
retweeted it i know i bookmarked it but
um it but to your point yes i used that
in the video uh that i did what about
three weeks four weeks ago okay okay so
that could have been it wasn't my i
didn't do that i didn't okay
if that's what you think just so just so
you know i was reading no that needed to
be clarified okay okay now this is from
a twitter thread that um that i was made
familiar with uh not too long ago um
this is in 2020.
this was going on um let me
i should does that work better i guess
that works better okay here we go so i
want to just give you a quick background
here just so you guys know i love jordan
peterson that man changed my life like
i stopped drinking because of him
i i started building my youtube channel
because of him like
he changed my life but
when i watched this before this is not
my first time watching this i could not
help but notice that
rolo had some good points
as he always seems to
ruin a lot of things for me i'm not even
gonna lie to you i'm gonna just uh yeah
what led up to all of this and again
this is not this is not a burn but i
want you to see what the process is here
okay so this is the jordan
i did not do this i am not responsible
for this i don't know who this guy is
rational disconnect but
so
michaela started with the lion diet
which consists of only eating beef salt
in water
although this uh verges on an eating
disorder michaela claimed that it cured
many of her health problems as we have
heard throughout all of these videos
she even announced that she stopped
taking her medication including an
anti-herpes drug
okay so what's that drug that's this
right here you see that there we go
okay the what what he's mentioning is
the valtrex at the very bottom of that
now what is valtrex valtrex is this
it is used to treat infections caused by
a certain type of virus
in children it is used to treat cold
sores in the mouth
which is a herpes simplex chickenpox uh
in adults it is used to treat shingles
caused by herpes zoster cold sores
around the mouth and uh is also used to
treat outbreaks of genital herpes so
that was what everybody was was making a
big deal out of back in the day so there
you have that
uh then she uh then convinced her father
to start uh start her diet soon after
starting jordan reported that he stopped
taking his antidepressants as well
so you've got dad on antidepressants and
you've got daughter on antidepressants
this were part of the
that thread throw that in there
now this is where i wanted to get to
okay it was around this time
that peterson reported not being able to
sleep for about four 25 days straight
while experiencing
what
an overwhelming sense of impending doom
after drinking some apple cider i will
say this family has the worst luck when
it comes to health [ __ ]
like
that stuff has to be genetic because
yeah
but it was just physical oh jesus i was
so dead but i didn't want to not do it
that was all cider like what was it
what was it doing
oh it it produced an
overwhelming sense of impending doom
and i seriously been overwhelming like
there's no way i could have lived like
that if that would have lasted for
see michaela knew by that point that it
would probably only last a month and i
was like a month yeah [ __ ] cider
oh i didn't sleep that that month i
didn't sleep for 25 days i didn't sleep
at all i didn't sleep at all for 25 days
how is that possible
i'll tell you how it's possible you lay
in bed uh frozen in something sounds
like hell hell approximating terror for
eight hours and then you get up oh my
god oh yeah and this is from [ __ ]
cider from science that's what we
thought yeah i mean look
again
i don't know what the hell i'm talking
about
i'm i'm ending it there because that's
where the clip ends okay
if you want to see that also available
on
joe rogan's show all right let's keep
going it was because of this anxiety
caused by a severe autoimmune reaction
to food
quote unquote that uh jordan was
prescribed benzos benzes okay
benzodiazepine
which was uh increased after his wife
was diagnosed with cancer this led to
peterson's developing a physical
dependence on the medication
again you can read this later i'll put
this in now
why this is not to beat up on the the
family here i know it probably sounds
like i am but i have to sort of lead up
to this so you know where we're going
when we get to the kill to party dynamic
here okay
according to michaela after multiple
failed rehabs attempt rehab attempts she
claims
almost killed him
peterson was moved to russia for
alternative treatments
the unknown treatment put peterson into
a medically induced coma for eight days
and gave him neurological damage so if
you think that peterson is not quite the
same peterson as he was back in 2018
that might be why
now here we go in the middle of her
father's hospitalization michaela left
her husband and dad to travel around
romania with andrew tate
his words not mine a misogynist pick-up
artist which
is not but and webcam pimp who runs a
scam website and thinks that depression
doesn't exist
and of course that's when you get the
infamous picture here
and you get the one that i showed you
just not too long ago
look at her eyes
you can kind of tell she's into him okay
where she's hanging out
enjoying herself and i'm going to just
throw this i'll throw this other one up
here in just a second um
this is
the infamous picture right there
that doesn't look like a girl who's like
fearful that her dad's gonna die or
worried about what her husband is
thinking uh in any sense again no hate
on tight no hate on tape hey tate's
gonna do what tate's gonna do
however
here you have michaela peterson taking
time out of her busy schedule and her
father's medical regimen who's in a
medically induced coma
to go to romania and hang out with the
tates
or at least him oh we'll come back to
that home a little premature that's the
one i wanted right there this is another
one again this is when everybody sorry
i'm gonna have more thoughts i swear but
i need to let him get through this part
so i swear there's gonna be more just
wait hits up on the tapes about like his
connection with michaela that's what
everybody gets to
just
throwing that out there side note
michaela's husband is from russia
thus andre right
claims to be possessed by a demon named
igor
and is the one who helped makayla get
her dad into russia for those treatments
next this time this entire time michaela
was charging people fifty to six hundred
dollars for memberships to her diet
website that offered virtually nothing
the site is now defunct for a second
time and was basically just a support
group for people claiming that the diet
cured them but does it work for anyone
you guys can again that's kind of
immaterial to everything that's going on
um well it apparently didn't work for
her father as we have already seen it
didn't work for her because she admitted
that she also took anti-anxiety drugs
while on her diet and it didn't help her
mother who was diet who was on the diet
and was diagnosed with kidney cancer
requiring two surgeries again that's
immaterial to what we're talking about
here
do we know if that's all from the diet
or if they just because it seems like
this family just has a lot of health
issues like even when she was younger
but that's not really the point of this
video like to me that's that's kind of
irrelevant like i don't want to say i
don't care like i empathize
and i really enjoy jordan peterson but
you know people are gonna do what
they're gonna do and then last but not
least um
peterson finishes treatment in russia
they went to florida and eventually
ended up in serbia where michaela gave
her entire family covid hospitalizing
jordan yet again
and the crazy thing is that as far as i
can tell jordan hasn't talked directly
to the media since in 2019 all updates
have come through his daughter now that
of course this was back in 2020 so
take that to be whatever you want to
want it to be
well a couple of things then just in
regards to your video a number of weeks
ago
so
first i think i should address the
andrew tate situation
[Music]
listen let's listen
she's a nice lady nothing happened i
spoke to her a bit
she was in germany i think i said hey
germany's romania is not so far away
come visit we'll go see some castles
okay i'm just curious we're just gonna
fly
from
germany
to romania
um
wait i gotta say length
just curious oh two hour flight okay i
could see how that's actually pretty
close
okay
it'll be fun we'll jump in one of my 17
super cars
and that's what we did that's the story
translation i [ __ ] the shot
[Laughter]
she's a nice she's a nice girl she's a
nice girl and uh
that's it i i i'm not really a fan of
her dad's i know her dad said some smart
stuff and i know he said some cool stuff
i've seen a couple clips i'm not a
stupid fan or nothing i've never watched
him from head to toe or anything like
that
um oh my god i heard a video of him
saying that he hooks up with girls to
like get power
was this a power move oh my gosh it is
what it is that's all that's all it is
i'm not gonna say any more than that so
sorry sorry boring answer but that's the
answer
there you go there's our good friend
so
before i went to russia this was october
before my dad is was in the hospital
before i went to russia i was in germany
and andrew tate invited me to come
see his house and talk business
and he flew me over there
for a day
i was there for a day he was talking
about starting a pay wall trying to
figure out how to monetize content
and then i flew home
and so we took a couple of photos one's
in the cigar lounge
but just because i flew over there
and talked to him doesn't mean there was
anything sexual that occurred which is
what happened when the internet saw that
photo
okay
this is what i need to add
ladies if you put yourself in a
situation
where people are gonna assume you hooked
up with a guy
for all intents and purposes you may as
well have hooked up with him
because everyone's gonna assume that
anyway if you accept a flight from a
man you may as well sleep with him at
that point like
i'm not advocating for that type of
stuff i'm just saying look and i'll give
you an example so
i went to do a collab with this rapper
okay for my channel i thought it'd be a
really funny video
i knew if i shoot showed up by myself
people would just assume we hooked up
so what did i do i bring my dad my
father he
um
it was a funny seed but this is what i'm
saying like
and i've been in situations where i did
not hook up with a guy but i put myself
in a situation where people like would
assume we like hooked up like i was at
his house late or like it was just the
two of us and i remember thinking like
like because guys will lie about that
stuff at times they will say you did
stuff even if you didn't because you
know ego thing especially when you're
younger you know and i remember thinking
like i may as well have hooked up with
him because everyone thinks i did so i
may as well just did it even though i
didn't
yeah that's that's my point if you put
yourself this is what i've learned as
i've gotten older if you put yourself in
that situation like people are gonna
assume what they're gonna assume and
i
would rather bring someone that can
vouch for me and say that i didn't do
that that was like there if that makes
sense
but yeah of course is what andrew has
said on pretty much any time i've taught
i actually interviewed him right after
that because of course everybody wants
to know what was going on right so when
you put something yeah out at that time
um that's what everybody's gonna gonna
say and he's pretty much said exactly
what you have said as well so um in fact
i think i even mentioned that i i i
pointed it out in the fresh and fit
video as a matter of fact where they
were interviewing him about that about
that those i guess just a couple of
pictures
um but you guys probably there's a bit
of inference that maybe something had
occurred so i just wanted to set that
straight right right
so so that's the first thing um the
second thing is can i can i ask yeah
yeah okay um so that was in october of
2019
and you were in germany 2019.
so you were already in germany at that
time
or yeah i'd been in germany
i'd flew from toronto to germany i was
in germany for business and then on the
way home i stopped in romania for a day
okay
and then
january
that might have been 2018. but he flew
you out there correct i thought you had
notes michaela
i'm sorry but she knows the date
i don't want to say she's capping
because she may she may have forgotten
but
if you if you had notes about all the
points you were trying to contend with
you didn't have actual dates
all you have to do is look in your phone
when when you guys took the picture
on the way back yes
from germany to romania or all the way
germany to romania and then romania to
canada okay it's like i'm busy but
i'll come see i was interested in what
he's done he's made a lot of money he's
put things behind a paywall and i kind
of wanted to learn
he seems like an interesting character
so i thought that could be interesting
were you aware what he does for a living
no
cap
look at her she looked up
actually i look up when i talk to so
maybe that's not
what is it up to the left that means
lying i don't remember but
cap come on come on you do a quick you
didn't google the guy
that was buying you a flight come on
michaela just be honest
look i went to a pickup event
i went to a pickup event with literally
guys that are pickup artists
and
like people could assume what they want
to assume about that right they could
make assumptions but i never put myself
in a situation where i was alone with
anyone and they could say i did anything
i didn't
so
yeah i don't know
okay he told me once he got there it's
not like he was oh sorry my point was i
forgot my point was that
like the pickup event was um
sketchy like like that's a weird group
i'm not gonna pretend i didn't know what
it was but i'm nosy like just say you're
nosy
whatever hiding anything how did you
guys like me
so like online oh over instagram
okay
yeah during slid and tear dm like let me
let's let me
you already know what i'm about to do
let's go to
i hope i did not oh no no not my inbox
not my inbox oh no
no
oh no
i'll just leave it i don't even care
okay but
but um
what was i gonna do
i was gonna look up andrew
a andy or andrew
tate
let's see
oh maybe you wouldn't know by his
instagram
huh
i guess it doesn't say on here maybe she
wouldn't know let's do the beacons
um
proven ways to make money online my
official website tic tac
free training
okay that kind of checks out what do you
guys think do you think that checks out
2019 i guess
i can't if that was 2019 or 2018.
um
that would have been 2018 october 2018 i
think
because 2019 it was january 2019
hopefully i'm getting the year right
when i went to russia with my dad
yeah
no sorry no 2019 is right and then it
was 20 20. we went to russia with dad so
in your video you said oh
she brought her dad to russia and then
while he was in the hospital went off
and you know partied with andrew tate
which wasn't right because that was four
months earlier three months earlier
i just wanted to clarify that well
that's the information that i had
available to me
yeah well he tweeted the photo out three
or four months later but i mean photos
can be taken whenever and then tweet it
out later
so
that's the first thing i wanted to
address and then
you okay so a couple of things
i think part of the reason maybe it
feels like you have
something against me or you think i'm
one of those women that doesn't want to
have kids or didn't want a kid in the
first place
and going back to my tom bill you
podcast where i say
having scarlet put a kibosh on my life
i just wanted to clarify i did not mean
having the kid was the issue
the best place to start to explain that
is in a day and age where people are
having kids later and later and later in
life you chose as a ambitious person as
far as i can tell to have kids in your
20s
so why don't we start there how
thoughtful was that was that accidental
was it something you put a lot of
thought
into oh that's an interesting place to
start
that is a very complicated story
actually
i
scarlet was an accident so i was in
university
i'd done two years in psychology and
then i'd switched over to biomedical
science and i was in my second year
and i got pregnant and i
kept her because i couldn't
emotionally handle any other option
and it was
extremely stressful because i was
23
when i got pregnant
and my
life plan was to have kids
ideally before the age of 30.
but i'm also like you said very career
oriented okay but this is where as women
we get emotional and she's like
but rolo i would never say that about my
kids
but he's not he's not talking about that
it's a dynamic that's what he's talking
about it's like a
it's a dynamic it's not saying you
regret your daughter when she didn't
exist but like
it wasn't convenient at the time that's
what he's talking about and i was
in my second year of university so that
was not ideal for you know when to have
a kid
but
but i decided to keep her and i ended up
dropping out of university
and then
doing part-time work for my dad and
which turned into full-time work very
rapidly when scarlett was about six
months old but
the choice to
have i didn't really feel like i had a
choice like i i ended up um when i when
i got healthy i stopped taking all my
medication including birth control
because you were worried about what it
was doing to you from a gut perspective
yeah well not even from a from a gut
perspective but also from a
psychological perspective like my mom
told me that when she'd gone on birth
control it had made her severely
depressed and she hadn't recognized that
until she stopped taking it i've heard a
lot of negative side effects of birth
control
but i really
i really haven't been on birth control
that long in my adult adult life like
like i barely was ever on it so i never
had any of them but i've heard really
bad things to be honest uh and i kind of
laughed that off but um i started taking
birth control when i was 14
and i was severely depressed so
hoop earrings uh duly noted thank you
very much uh oh by the way this
interview is with uh what'd you say his
name was uh tom biliu that's what it was
uh and this was from july 8th i i should
have told you the date before i started
oh my god hoop earrings are a trend
rollo they're a trend look
again i'm cheap
so i don't have hoop earrings because i
i don't buy nice things and i'm not
trendy
and i'm poor right now i'm very poor
please put a like on the video hit that
subscribe button to help a girl out but
like they're just trendy right now if
that's if that's the standard for how
every girl is gonna be it because that's
all i see to be honest especially
like six months ago maybe that was like
very much the trend but this was on july
8th of this year
i thought who cares if you add another
pill on top of it i'm already depressed
um which was like an immature way of
thinking about it uh as a 14 year old
might but when i was 23 and i stopped
taking my medications and i got
healthier i was like i don't want
anything impacting my mental function
and so i stopped taking birth control
just in case it was and i do believe
that i was having
i do believe it was causing depression
but it wasn't the only thing in my life
that was causing depression at that
point but yeah i did stop taking it and
that ended up
resulting in scarlet who i'm thrilled to
have but it definitely put a bit of a
kibosh on the direction i thought my
life was going to take however it ended
up not being a negative thing it ended
up being a positive thing but it was
scary
yeah there's a lot of interesting stuff
in that so one it put a kibosh on my
personal life sound like killed a party
sure does to me
now i'm not saying she's going to kill
her child obviously she's not however
that is the motivation that's what i'm
talking about
is the hindrance factor i meant that i'd
had this plan in my head where i went to
university and was able to support
myself because of my university degree
and i chose to have scarlet and had to
rearrange my life around that but going
back i would not change that decision i
would have changed the decision to get
married
because i wasn't in a good relationship
so it had nothing okay it wasn't this is
where we get emotional as women
i love my daughter
my daughter like i don't regret my
daughter
[Music]
michaela
you know like
you know you would have preferred to
have your daughter with the right guy
now i i know that's a really harsh thing
to say because you don't wish your
daughter didn't exist you love her you
want her here but
if you had to do it over again would you
really get knocked up at 22
you wouldn't have your your kid with
someone you wanted to be with the rest
of your life and not been a single
mother who would pick that
come on like i i know it worked out and
that's great but
scarlett that was the issue there it was
that i shouldn't have
gotten married to someone i wasn't
supposed to be with that wasn't a good
match
because that wasn't good for anybody
that was the mistake it wasn't scarlet
so i wanted to clarify that in case it
sounded like going back oh i wouldn't
have had a kid well when when i was
covering that aspect of in that show
when i was covering that aspect and i
was looking at whether tom billy i hope
i'm saying his name right yeah um
i mean in that episode you mentioned
that scarlet was an accident
was like certainly an unplanned
pregnancy let's just be honest
um so
and you were what 23 24 when that
happened 23 yeah yeah so what i was
doing again i think a lot of people when
they watch that they think that i was
making a hit piece or an attack piece on
you i was trying to use
ellie
sorry guys my dog
is annoying as hell do you as well as
brittany renner uh was it uh tommy
lahren
i think my dog was my kill the party
because
i got a dog at 21
and i'm gonna be honest that was i
stopped drinking at 22.
and i should i should clarify i say stop
drinking there were there were times
where i drank like i i've been
i haven't had a drop of alcohol in like
maybe six months to a year now
but
i stopped like i moved cities and then i
stopped going out and then i would maybe
only drink a couple times a year so it
got like significantly less at 22.
so yeah my kill the party face and my
epiphany phase was at 22.
and several other examples as well you
your name happened to be one of them and
it was illustrating an example
of how
children end up being a hindrance to a
woman she wasn't quite she wasn't a
hindrance but i know that's what you're
getting emotional michaela you're an
emotional
he's talking about it was an
inconvenience to your life
it was you just said that oh my god
that's what i wanted to clarify
she wasn't a hindrance but you said
exactly what he said you said exactly
like that stopped me from going to
university but
if i went back and didn't have scarlet
not going to university was actually the
right decision going to university and
getting the degree i was getting
wouldn't have helped me out anyway
so
yeah when you have a kid parts of your
life are harder to do like yeah i
couldn't go out and drink every weekend
but that's not a fulfilling life anyway
so
hindrance would it have been a
fulfilling life at 23 rather than 29
would it have been a fulfilling life at
23
rather than at 29. so you're saying you
would have been fulfilled at 23.
oh you definitely when he said like the
making up for missing out you definitely
feel like you miss out on some stuff
when you stop partying and drinking i
never kid i had a dog but
yeah that's real because
i think as women like we always want to
be included in like a part of things but
i don't know when you party you just
realize that everyone is there just to
i don't know like ever like
like you think you have pals you know
you think you have like real friends and
then you realize oh the guys are just
here to sleep with me
and the girls just want someone to drink
with so
like i said i wouldn't go back what i
would have changed is i shouldn't have
gotten married but because michaela you
know you would you why would you pick i
want to be a single mom nobody wants to
be a single parent that caused a whole
bunch of problems and
that's that was the issue i love your
dad though like no hate to you if you
see this michaela no hate
tell your dad i said hey
well let's just be real okay do you
think you should have had the kid out of
wedlock then because and in the time the
reason i asked well see this is tom bill
you an interview and you were saying you
didn't want to be an unmarried mother no
i didn't and that's the problem i had
when i was 23. i was like okay
i have an unplanned pregnancy
and the most stable way to raise a child
is in a
family with a man and a woman i agree
and so bite the bullet get married and
figure out how to make it work and
negotiate until you have a proper
relationship
and so that was my thinking when i was
23
and
i wasn't able to negotiate that
relationship
and
i suppose every divorce you know it's
always the
other person who's in the wrong so i
don't know how that works exactly or
what my point is but
that was not a good like that was not a
good place to be and what i ended up
deciding um and it wasn't actually this
year when we decided to get divorced we
decided to get divorced in 2018.
but it got stretched out for a number of
years and i can get into that if i need
to
but the reason
were they separated
the reason it took
martin no
i don't understand why
maybe maybe i'm just young and naive but
to me
if you're separated you might as well be
divorced like you're getting divorced
what's the difference
um part of the reason it took a while is
because i wanted to be absolutely sure
that breaking up the family was better
for everyone
and not just for me
so it was one foot in one foot out can i
do better
is it
yes 100 everybody is happy your
positions kind of changed then since 23
or 23 year old versus what are you 29
you'll be 30 next year right
you see him this subtle he's like
epiphany phase
making up for missing out kill the party
dynamic look at him
yeah
um
yeah my position's changed my position
hasn't changed that a two-parent family
is healthier for a kid but a two-parent
family that's fighting all the time
isn't healthier than being separated i
agree with that i 100 agree with that
but
i also
i mean i'm young right my opinion could
change on this but i i don't think
there's a lot of reasons that you really
should get divorced um
like infidelity that's one
sorry guys i think a girl has a right to
leave if he's being
unfaithful um
infidelity like abuse
oh god i'm kind of tired but there's
more i swear there's more and not being
filled in a house that's full of
resentment and anger
now because
now correct me if i'm wrong because i'm
i don't know him personally but it seems
by all
let's just say impressions that andre is
pretty good with with your daughter
is very andre is very good with my job
very i mean
you have to understand the impression
that i have and pretty much everybody
else has when we're seeing nothing but
instagram shots of andre with the kid
and you off doing what with the tates
first of all and then second of all um
you know doing doing what you're doing
right now um so well is there part of
the is there something else like that
that people don't know that
that you know well it's like he's not
he's not as good as the impressions are
because i'm
certainly not gonna
i'm certainly not gonna say anything
negative about andre okay you may as
well have
look we're women we run our mouths i'm
not i've done it
i say please don't do it please don't do
it pearl don't do it but i do it i do it
sometimes i try not to though anyways
um
anyways by saying what you're saying
you're implying that he did something
wrong
so let us know the t um
i want to know ever period
so so that's just bottom line but part
of the reason i don't have scarlet all
over my instagram is because i have tons
of followers he has her own private
account and my extended family follows
that private account so if i do put up a
picture of her her private account is
curious if michaela
started posting with her daughter after
this
um
is that my ck
oh [ __ ]
let me just look at peterson
here we go let's hear any of these with
her daughter
um
when did she post this
three weeks ago that's about
oh my gosh this
right after the interview
but this is a different kid
okay so right after the interview she
posts with interesting
interesting
tagged but i don't let people who don't
know or follow her i will say that
that is how you get your kid like what
do they say it's like safer to keep your
kids off the internet because it's child
cat trafficking i'm not really a warrior
um when i have kids
i don't know i'll cross that bridge when
i get there i put my dog on the internet
for sure
but i guess it's a little different than
a child
so that's that's part of the reason okay
yeah
i just didn't wasn't sure like at the
beginning when she was really little
there were pictures of her up on my
instagram if you scroll all the way down
baby pictures and then when she got a
bit older it was like
i don't know if maybe that's appropriate
or not but then oh my gosh that's
advertising that's what he says
so when she was younger she was still
with the guy and then she's like trying
to leave so she stops posting the kid
so i made her a private account
when um so you were mentioning that you
had already decided that you were going
to like at least separate or because i
know you were on a break
at the time that you were in romania
with uh the tates at that time and i
think you've been pretty public about
that so i don't think i'm revealing
anything there um so
as far back as at least 2018 you were
already making plans or you'd already
discussed divorcing or separating is
that what i'm getting
okay 2018. and then
and then what happened was
we were living separately
and
my parents got really sick
[Music]
and andre ended up and i know that this
can come across as using him
but this was a very complicated
situation my parents were in the
hospital over the summer i was taking
care of them like i ended up
andre went away so we were living
separately andre went away for about a
month he was in russia and i was taking
care of scarlet and then
after my mom had surgery for cancer
getting a babysitter going over there in
the morning
grabbing scarlett after she had a nanny
putting her to bed getting another
babysitter going back to take care of my
mom
so that was one of the months um and
then andre came back saw that i was in
really rough shape from all the stress
he started helping
and that was the summer and then my dad
got really sick
from benzodiazepine dependence and a
side effect called acathesia which
makes people suicidal
and so he was suicidal and
he went to rehab because we thought the
best way to deal with this was rehab
which wasn't right because they tried
stabilizing him with more medications
and because of those medications
well
yes so we went to like we you know spent
a bunch of money went to a private like
the best rehab center and they ended up
just stabilizing him putting him on more
medications the akathesia got worse
and so
he was there
brought him back to canada
and then he ended up in the hospital in
december
so that was
19 december 2019
and in the hospital they
sedated him with medications to
counteract this akathesia
so badly that when we went in there he
couldn't
communicate very well
and
my whole family flew down so my aunt my
uncle my grandparents everybody flew
down and we all talked about it and we
had been researching all over the world
to figure out where to bring them that
wouldn't keep adding on medications that
would just take them away
and the only place that looked honestly
kind of crazy enough to do that was
russia
and we went everywhere like i didn't
want to go to russia because i don't
speak russian and russia's terrifying so
i didn't want to do that but we tried
israel but they've got the same kind of
medical establishment where they just
keep adding on medications to stabilize
which doesn't work for academia because
it's a side effect
anyway so
the only way to get into russia and
andre was helping me at this point
because
my dad was in such bad shape in a
hospital that the fact that we were
getting divorced didn't seem as dramatic
as it normally would because we were
dealing with somebody who we thought was
gonna be in the hospital and then die
we're like okay
the divorce is a thing but
at this point
you know
yeah
so
we ended up
going to russia and we ended up getting
back together
but for the next
oh yeah
we just did primary care for my dad so
when we went to russia and he had his
detox
it was
okay so she's back with him before the
epiphany phase
i don't know
period of my entire life and online
i was just shown as this person who had
you know
put forced my dad onto my weird all meat
diet
and then dragged him to russia and
nearly killed him while gallivanting off
with other people
and that was when that tweet went out
which wasn't yours that 20 000 people
liked and i was in russian like my hair
was falling out from stress i couldn't
communicate very well with people
because i don't speak russian i was like
this is it's either this or dad's in
this hospital and he's gonna die and my
entire extended family agreed on that
so
that's the background there
um
so andre was instrumental in getting him
into russia we wouldn't have been able
to we would have been able to get him
into russia without andre because he had
a russian passport oh okay
but it but it wasn't just it wasn't just
that like he was with me helping take
care of my dad and i was
yeah
and so he was instrumental there so
people are online were like why aren't
you and even my dad why aren't you with
someone who's like a good dad he's he's
helping your family
and
i don't really want to get like i don't
want to get into the negatives because
i don't think it's appropriate but we
fought all the time in ways that i
couldn't negotiate and i don't think i'm
enough does that mean
negotiating reasonable person
and so the stress in our household
was really bad and i didn't think it was
good for scarlet either
and so separately
things are working out we're
communicating
and like i said i'm not going to like it
i'm not going to
villainize my kid's dad
like ever
yeah no
especially publicly so yeah
i get it i get it but i'm i'm i'm
curious to know like i mean you have to
go into details or anything like that
but
i mean i have seen interviews of you
well i think it was you and your mother
or something like that talking about how
you know building a relationship and
building that marriage or do you think
that that wasn't possible with andre no
it wasn't possible
okay was because uh
is there
is he about the same i don't know how
old he is is it about the is he in his
20s as well
no he's 31.
so he's 31. okay so he's just a touch
older than you yeah correct okay
well i was curious because i i mean a
lot of a lot of what i see on your
channel here um is really kind of
you know i guess relationship building
and particularly when you do interviews
with your mother you deal with your
father
it's it seems to me like it's it's
counterintuitive let's just say to what
is you know you portray on your on your
channel so i was just wondering is it is
it something that's just like
fundamentally a conflict that you can't
resolve or is it something that's like
just because you're at a certain age
because as you were saying before when
you were 23 you were thinking different
than you are now at 29. so
he's so smooth you hear that
i know exactly what he's got if you're
red pillow wear you know exactly what
he's getting at the epiphany phase ah no
disco she's thinking is he the best i
could do i could do better he's not the
best i could do that's what she's
thinking yeah i i get i get what you're
saying no i don't think it's an age
thing i think it took me a while to
realize that andre and i weren't
compatible i mean it also could be that
she tried
like i mean sometimes you like you love
a person you know and so you want to
make it work and you try hard to make it
work but then you're like this is hell
on earth
and we don't get along at all so maybe i
should try it
with someone else i've wanted to have
kids and have a family since i was like
16. and i wanted to do that young so 23
and you talk about it on your channel 23
is a good age to do that you talk about
wanting to party in missing years but
i had a rough teenage
hood
i drank a lot i was not happy when that
girl gets into her you know party or
party years or whatever else then it's
fomo
and it's yolo okay
yolo not rollo yolo you only live once
and fear of missing out
but i want to get back
it seems to me
you know party this is i always google
this chart
and i can never find it so
so i'm in my party years
okay
i peaked two years ago all right
uh i think i actually peaked at 19 if
i'm gonna be honest i think that's the
hottest i ever was
um
so
now i'm going to start looking for a
beta in two years i was talking about
this i think i date betas
i don't think any guy i've dated has
been like a conventional like alpha male
like i think i think i like
and torsha was saying maybe it's because
like we we can't get alphas and i'm like
maybe but
i like guys that are like funny
or more laid back because i think it
goes better with my personality because
i'm kind of up out there
so i like someone to be funny with me
and i don't think that's like alpha
or i like someone that's more
laid back and quiet so i can be like
i can it just like laughs at my jokes
basically
okay anyways
um
so then the beta so that comes around 27
and then
37 is alpha re-interest i'm just curious
what is the average age of divorce
of divorce
women for a woman
is
oh 30.
oh for real so that's like right around
the
but the average age of first marriage is
27. how does that work
okay ellie i need you to stop growling
i'm gonna do this video and then i'll
let you out come on
stop chilling party years or whatever
else then it's fomo
and it's yolo okay
yolo not rollo yolo you only live once
and fear of missing out
and michaela peterson is now
experiencing the fear of missing out
like i don't need to continue drinking
in order to fill some
you know fomo that i'm experiencing i'm
not experiencing fomo from partying i
don't drink
right like i wake up at six in the
morning i think the last time i had it i
had a couple of drinks on halloween
but
it's not my age that's changing how i
feel if anything i'm more upset now
because now i'm 29 and this would have
been
better to have sorted out when i was 24.
you talk about that too that like women
decline with age especially with
fertility so
no i would say it's it's the opposite
that is what i want like what i do want
is a family and a stable relationship
i'm not interested in hooking up with
people
people are gross in general like i don't
agree i'm not
so i'm curious what he means by the
party dynamic is it does it have to be
like drinking going out clubbing
partying
is it is it still valid even if you're
not doing those things that's a question
i have
yeah that's a question i have
so
because my mom went out with us like
i'm from a fun family okay like
it is not that big of a deal to go to a
bar
like my dad has never drank in his life
but my my other side
we'd all go out and have fun and like
shimmy you know but it wasn't like
it wasn't like like that you know it was
just like
fun and then you go home with your with
the fam i don't know i think the i think
the main issue i had with your video
because i can understand how i come off
online and i haven't really figured out
how to address that i've kind of been
ignoring it and like well that's a
problem but i'll just keep going to see
what happens um but
i didn't like the comparison
that you made between
me and what is her name casey anthony
who
murdered her kid and then put her in the
trunk so that she could go party
i thought that was not very nice
what the kill to party dynamic is this
is that when a woman has a child
especially when they have them earlier
on such as michaela peterson here
that child becomes a hindrance to
optimizing hypergamy okay this
this is why rolo is so misunderstood
because you hear this and you don't know
the context of what he's talking about
so immediately you're like god damn
i'm not a murderer what the f
but what he's talking about
is he's saying that women
it becomes a hindrance to our dating
life it lowers our smv
and it's mad and convenient like you
can't go out and you can't
do all the stuff now
it could end up being a good thing for
you
but
it doesn't it doesn't change the fact
that it's it's like inconvenient that is
in a nutshell
what the kill to party dynamic is about
so
when
we talk about how guys should not um
date single mothers for example when
when rich cooper or myself or anyone
else for that matter
uh says avoid single mothers well most
guys do
kind of naturally oh thank you for that
uh
sammy let me go and put that on there
that's actually a pretty good shot
sammy has come through
with the where'd it go
there we go let's see how this is our
good this is uh this is k uh casey
anthony all right where'd she go
where's my casey there's my casey
can we see casey there she is
2008 yeah gosh that was it that long ago
police in orange county
florida
received a call that led to one of
america's most high-profile criminal
cases that just oh that was when she did
it the disappearance and death of
two-year-old kaylee anthony i guess it
was her daughter my dad um and the
question of whether her mother casey
anthony the other one i guess was
involved there we go okay so that's
that's our good friend casey anthony in
case you wanted a visual reference of
what what is i'm actually talking about
here and i okay so let me i'll explain a
couple things to you here first um i'll
get to the epiphany phase in just a
second but
um when i brought up casey anthony i was
using that as the most extreme example
of what i call the kill to party dynamic
okay and what that is is that women who
have their children much younger
realize that is a an obstacle it is a
hindrance to them seeking out and
finding another partner finding a guy
who is better off for what they think at
least at that time is would be a have
been a better pairing for them
while they are still within that sort of
threshold of say like 18 to 28 years old
where i call it the party years other
people call it the whole phase whatever
you want to call you know when you're
having your fun and you're you know it's
it's when you can um
uh
when you can build things a little bit
more when women are at their prime
agency like i said before like we're
just like in a second ago is uh 23 is
where i've had most women have being
that their sexual market value peak
years that's crazy
i was so heartbroken
did not
when i was at my like peak i was not
doing anything i was just like being
depressed
as i said i epiphany phase at 22. i say
that for a number of reasons um
primarily it's because that's when men
find women the most attractive right
during that sort of 18 to 28 era
however when women have a child such as
you at 23 years old it tends to put a
damper on finding a guy who's better
than say the guy that they ended up
divorcing or the guy that they ended up
marrying and then divorcing during that
time so that was the example that i was
using i think what happens is this is
when i do something like that i wonder
if the party phase is like different for
each girl so maybe like your party phase
for michaela is more like the attention
from other guys maybe she slept with
them maybe she didn't but like being
able to hang out one-on-one
being like an internet celebrity all
that stuff when i use an example such as
kcn i'm not saying and i even said this
i don't know how many times during that
that
four hour video i'm not saying that
that's what you wanted to do okay i'm
just using casey anthony as one prime
example of that i used other examples as
well brittany renner for example
locking down pj washington with the kid
when when the time was right for hershey
of course is 29 years old as well
so i was using her as an example but
people
hone in on something as extreme as say
like casey anthony i tried to present
the fact that that was the extreme
example of that
however the more general example of that
dynamic is that when women have are
become single mothers particularly when
they become single mothers at an early
age it makes them less marketable in the
sexual marketplace
that's what i was getting at but of
course everyone in the comments goes he
just compared you to casey and this is
look here i i mean this is the most
respectful way like rollo isn't
like i really i like him right i think
the more you listen to him like the more
you understand what he's talking about
but like on camera to someone that
hasn't heard his content i don't think
he comes off as overly likable
so
a lot of times you have to watch a lot
of his content before you really
understand what he's saying
and oh gosh this next part hold up well
the thumbnail the thumbnail did have me
and i do thank you for picking a good
picture of me
explain to you the dynamics of thumbnail
creation which maybe you already know
but when you put people's face on there
when you put people's recognizable faces
on there when you have to see the whites
of their eyes and you're not the first
one i've ever done this with by the way
that's simply how you get impressions on
youtube right now i'm you know i'll be
all above board with that because i'm
not the first one to to figure this out
and uh definitely so so when you do
something like that then it gets then it
draws like i've said this before it's
like i understand that there's a
salaciousness there's the tmz effect
right it's the it's uh you want to give
give your audience the red meat however
when i do so i'm trying to give them
steak with the sizzle so i'm not doing
it just to say oh look here here's what
she did right that's
that's not my point i say that in the
beginning of every single one of my
videos especially when i go after
somebody who i i think would make a good
example of a particular like
illustration of a dynamic that i'm
talking about i talked about uh emma was
there emma thorne i think is what her
name was i talked about her on a couple
of different occasions um and you know
people don't have a problem with that
because that's him with porn and then
you're michaela peterson so when i do a
thumbnail like of her nobody's saying oh
you just compare he you know he just
compared youtube such and such it's not
an attack piece video i don't try to do
i don't do reaction videos i don't do
like takedown videos or anything like
that if i think that somebody serves as
a good illustration yeah and that's
that's what he's talking about it's just
this person fits in
i know he doesn't consider it a theory
but i would still say red pill somewhat
theory
but this is this is the theory or what
is called a praxeology that i follow and
this is the person but it's really hard
when it's you
not to take that [ __ ] personal
for a dynamic that i've written about in
the past or that i'm talking about
currently you know with whatever that
i'm doing then yes i'll do that because
it's a recognizable say oh okay now i
get what he's saying so it's it's more
of like an illustration rather than like
oh i'm going to take you down bro i need
you to do kanye west and i need you to
do it even more now because now we got
julia fox in the mix
was kanye kim's beta
and julia fox's alpha but no cause julie
fox is 31. anyways please i'm i'm
begging you for this video in every
single video that i do this in i put out
the standard caveat this is not about
the individual this is about what's
going on so let's talk about what the
dynamic is not about it's not an attack
but this is youtube this is twitter this
is instagram this is social media so
everybody wants to see like what we call
a youtube bloodsport they want to see
like oh did you see that he compared you
to this did you see you compared to that
i talked about this uh recently on um on
elijah schaefer show as well so um it's
it's there's this
um i think there's this need for people
to have sort of this get to get a rise
out of you i was on i was on you are
here with elijah shaffer and
sydney watson and ariel i forget her
last name scarcella or scarella she's
the you know lesbian
you know uh traditional conservative i
guess now
and
when i was on there and we were having
our back and forth
everyone in the chat wanted us to like
be at each other's throats right because
they're looking for that it's bread and
circuses
so when i put something out like that or
if there's some kind of comparison to
you to like say casey anthony that's not
my intent to do that but that's what the
audience wants to see
you see what i'm saying so maybe you're
getting the wrong impressions you're
like i'm not trying to make you look
like casey anthony i just mentioned you
in the same show as
casey anthony
okay i guess i just don't usually play
into that
like on my channel i get the clickbaity
stuff but if i'm like doing it probably
no i really don't as you're doing it
though no i really don't i definitely
have not made an indirect comparison
between someone and someone who murdered
her child and put her in a trunk well
oh my god
this
this comment made me so mad because
michaela you know what he's trying to
say like if you watch the whole video
he says so many times i'm not saying she
would do this but it's the same dynamic
why are we so emotional as women
i know she's not like getting emotional
but like you can tell it's like a
personal reaction
i don't know
that was not my intent anyways okay well
i'm really glad to hear that that makes
me feel better and then let's see what
else do i have then we can get to your
book that was so sassy okay finding god
as convenient
my problem isn't the actual sincerity of
the belief i mean they can say whatever
they want we can decide to believe it or
not women get off scot free because
we're not supposed to be judgmental
god forbid a guy be judgmental that by
the way being judgmental is the cardinal
sin of the new the new world religion
which is emotionalism which is femaleism
right
be judgmental and that is a sin you need
to atone for my friend
and you know what the worst one is is
not believing when believe all women if
you don't believe all women that's a sin
why because you're judging them
because you have some sort of
discernment you go you know what that
sounds like [ __ ] to me how dare you
judge me like that
be more judgmental i've said this over
and over again and i really gotta do it
that's what i said i think we need to
bring bullying back
bring it back people
i'm just kidding the internet kind of
has a whole different type of bullying
but
oh my gosh i thought about this when i
was in catholic school there's this girl
that came to the school and was like
look ladies
okay she said she said it better than
this
she said it very emotionally and like
heartfelt but like
all in all she was like yeah i've been
ran through but even though i did all
that i still found my husband and i'm
like
is this like a blueprint but she's like
but don't do what i did i'm like but you
no i'm not
i'm not saying like i went on to do the
same thing what i'm saying was i
literally was thinking like
so so you did whatever you wanted
partied got that out of your system and
then still found the husband
what the
ma'am
ma'am
why are you talking to us about this
show on judgment
i would like to say i swear to god i
think rolo tomasi would be a more
effective chastity speaker in schools
because i remember i couldn't put my
finger on why
but i remember thinking this lady
was i don't want to say full [ __ ] but
kind of
but i think rollo's like more rational
point of view would have spoken more to
me as a teenager but i guess i'm
i'm kind of weird
i mean it's convenient for me because i
feel significantly better than i did
but the convenience i guess from the
outside view would be oh she finds god
and then suddenly she's getting divorced
and forgive all her past sins because
christianity is about forgiveness and
there's the convenience there
but
we've been getting divorced extremely
slowly since 2018 and part of the reason
it was slow was because of this
absolute catastrophe that occurred with
my mom and my dad
so but ma'am you still got back with him
you know you did
i understand that you have your whole
like epiphany phase and i can see the
pattern there
[Music]
but i think you want me to explain
what
well it's just like is it convenient
does that just an age when people find
religion or is it when they fake it
again i got baptized at like 20 21 22.
well i was i was grow i grew up catholic
and i have okay i'll tell you guys my
stance on religion
now i'm this is not the best stance i'm
not gonna lie to you but this is this is
how i feel i think that catholics make
the most sense when i listen to debates
and stuff and i don't know if it's
because i was raised that
but
when i was looking at religion
because i spent like a year just like
going to bible study and trying to
figure out what religion i was and i
narrowed it down to like christian like
some sort of christian
catholic
or jewish now when i saw the
requirements to be jewish i threw that
one out
i'm sorry
i don't believe it that bad i just don't
second one
basically the biggest difference between
catholic and christians catholics go to
the church
when when there's like
a debate about scripture christians say
read your bible follow what the bible
says catholics go to the church now
i don't want to get too deep into this
but basically
i thought catholics make more sense
because what you're going to have every
individual person like come up with it
for themselves and come to the same
conclusion i don't think so but you know
on the other hand catholics like
like you know big institutions obviously
become corrupt at some point but that's
every institution so
with power anyways
so my my thought was
i hate catholic mass i could not go to
catholic mass every day the right like
every week the rest of my life
but i love christian mass and i feel
closer to god when i go there
and i don't have these like super strong
opinions where i'm like that one's right
that one's right so i'm gonna go
christian because
it just makes more sense to me right now
um
now don't get me wrong since i moved
here i really need to find a church that
has not been high enough on my to-do
list
because i'm very stressed out here i'm
not even gonna lie to you not
kind of an excuse i know sorry
but
oh my god i got so off topic oh my god i
got so off topic
my point is
oh my god then i found my i forgot my
point i totally oh it's so embarrassing
religion
i believe that it's uh
i believe that it is when women find
their find religion or they get back
with uh they want to sort of rediscover
their roots once they get to the point
where as i said before like the 18 to 28
year
range whatever the whole phase of the
party years whatever you want to call it
right around the time when women hit
about 29 years old 29 to 31 right in
that that range is what i call the
epiphany phase and the epiphany is this
i had an epiphany that suddenly i need
to get right with god i need to make
guys uh do i'm going to do things the
right way i had my fun in the past and
now i'm going to get serious you will
see this constantly again this is not me
just pulling this out of my ass here you
will see this constantly in
tinder or tinder profiles you'll see
this constantly in ginge bumble with the
dating profile name the name the the
platform and you will see women of that
age right around 29 to 31 years old all
of the profiles are very similar which
is i had my fun in the past i'm done
with the jerks i'm done with the
yeah i was so crazy in my college years
um looking for something serious if
you're not looking for something serious
swipe left
you probably understand what i'm saying
it's so common that i can go on like the
guys that i follow or the the people who
are sort of in my sphere of influence i
guess
um constantly come up with you know the
screen caps of exactly that same thing
now i i
developed i guess this idea as far back
as like say 2010
so when i put it in my my book
the rational mail in well i published in
2013 but from discussions that i had
prior to publishing that book that's
what we called the epiphany phase and
the epiphany phase is this they come
women come to an epiphany at right
around 29 years old that they can no
longer compete in a sexual marketplace
like they used to in the past
and so now there is this
i think psychological need for women to
find some sort of rationalization to
explain why they did what they did
between the ages of say 18 and 28 and
why they want to go ahead and find a
long-term mate
after that and usually that comes with a
rediscovering of religion
usually that comes with a new
record i guess prerequisites for guys
to jump through certain hoops to qualify
to to
to women's demands i guess or women's
standards let's just say for the long
term
so prior to the epiphany phase
it was more about sort of alpha seed
after uh after the epiphany phase is
more beta need
and i define that it's of course and
your father knows this as well that's
that is hypergamy okay so hypergamy is
this it's alpha seed and beta need and
too many people
tend to focus on just the beta needs
side of things so because it sounds
right it sounds good right oh she found
god that sounds good great come back to
the fold right uh she's had her journey
of self-discovery now she wants to like
do things the right way we're going to
do this the right way
i would love to see rolo react to my
chastity speakers from my high school
christina everett everest christina and
jason everett google them google so at
right around 29 to 31 years old
is is at that what i call that the
epiphany phase and after that you know
all bets are off i guess but right then
it's when women are acknowledging that
they can no longer compete
in at the same level that they could
when they were 23 years old so now
things sort of change and there's this
sort of convenient rationalization of
getting back and i'm not saying that you
didn't sincerely find god i'm just
saying i'm talking about the convenience
of it or the timing of it because people
have hit me up on this before and i'll
explain this right now people will say
well don't you think don't you think
that that women are actually sincerely
um you know finding god at this point or
are they aren't they sincerely i think
that's when they start to face
consequences people
make changes when there are consequences
if you take away the consequences for
things
people act a certain way like i talk
about this all the time thank god for
consequences
i would not be a good person if i didn't
have consequences
so
yeah i would say around if you've spent
your entire 20s
partying
around 29 to 30
is probably when you'd you know start to
see the consequence but the problem is
michaela's gonna be like well i didn't
even drink
i didn't even like do any of this stuff
that you're talking about and i relate
to that a little bit because
like i might i'll go out with my friends
sure but i don't drink i don't like
i don't know do any of the crazy stuff
that you see
and
and i barely and i've barely even done
that since i was 22.
so
i put this like
that's that's where we get that like gut
reaction
that's like what the rolo i didn't do
that but you have to understand he's
talking about theory he doesn't mean
that every single person does it exactly
the same way your party phase might just
be attention
so anyways sort of like uh personal
transformation
and i say yeah i do believe that i think
that if you right now if you took a
polygraph test that say do you sincerely
believe what you believe you probably
passed the polygraph test but i'm what
i'm focusing on is the convenience and
the timing of that particular
epiphany at that at that stage of
maturity for women because it is so
constant that i think that men need to
be aware of that so that's why i say
that now the the god aspect of all this
and i don't know if you are aware but my
fourth book is the rational male
religion and i've talked about red pill
aspects in the course of religion
now i'm not a theologian i've never gone
to seminary i don't have a degree in any
of this but i'm a keen observer of human
nature and and evolutionary psychology i
have a little bit of a background in
religion but not not certainly not like
your father okay so
that being my caveat there when we talk
about people finding religion roosh v is
i don't if you're familiar with roosh
but roof is like recently watched and
said recently he's like more like two or
three years ago now has you know decided
that he wants to become an orthodox
christian and give up his sort of pick
up his ways and you know he's sort of i
don't see he's a hermit but he's kind of
you know decided that he's going to
isolate himself and so suddenly at 40
years old he's decided that he's going
to you know rediscover god and he's you
know that's all he wants to talk about
and yes i understand that his sister
died and yes i know that there was a set
of circumstances so do men go through
the epiphany phase two i'm just
wondering is there like a men scale to
this
push them to that particular time
however that's not what i focus on what
i focus on is what i call the prodigal
son dynamic which is you were once
away from the faith you were partying
and drinking and having all your fun and
hookers and blow right you left your
father's house and you went off to seek
your fortunate you ever see that blue
mountain state episode
where he
the it's the funniest scene it's so
funny so there's this guy that's a big
player on the team right and um because
it's like about a football team that's
like out of college and the guy is the
biggest player hooks up with all the
girls does all the drugs does all the
stuff and they the team has to go to
church and he says to his teammate he
says i love church and the teammates
like
you
sir
you're you're like the furthest thing
from church
and so then he's like i can do whatever
i want i just got to say sorry after
and then during church he has sex with a
girl and the confessional and then he
walks out and he's like
sorry god like what
didn't work out the way that you wanted
it to and now you come back
and you say oh you know what i've
rediscovered god i want to come back to
the family i don't care i'll go eat with
the pigs or whatever and
the father and that the the family all
welcome you back with open arms right if
the prodigal son
story is not about the prodigal son it
is about the father and it is about the
the family that welcomed the son back
because what happens is when you have
that prodigal son dynamic going on or
the prodigal daughter in this case
it's a reaffirmation of faith
for the people who are already
always with that faith so they're happy
to bring you back in and particularly
with christianity it's based on
forgiveness so when you combine the
prodigal son with forgiveness yeah of
course it doesn't matter keep coming
back in go go out with
you know go out seek your fortune fall
flat on your face and come right back
it's a reaffirmation of the faith for
the people who are all who never left
the fold and so that's why i wanted to
point out the fact that when women or
even in this case guys depending on on
what their case is when they rely on
that prodigal son dynamic it's the
people who are it's not the guy it's the
it's the people who are welcoming that
person back because it reaffirms their
faith
i think she i think she's lost
okay okay
i think i have i have got a couple of
comments for that
um one
okay one how do you know that if there
is some sort of pattern about women
finding god around the age of 29 how do
you know that's not just a stage of
brain development
and do you know what age it happens for
men
i think she's trying to gotcha question
him
didn't work sweetie did not work pretty
much gather that it's not so much brain
development um i know that uh i know
that right up until about 20 i think
it's just consequences that's when women
start to face consequences they're like
oh [ __ ]
i got like
two five years to find someone to have a
kid with
i spent the last 10 years partying
oh [ __ ] consequence consequence how can
i fix this
boom church 21 years old human beings
brains are developing right up until
that point
well for men it's 26.
for women 24 24 26 women mature
physically faster than men understood
so
i mean at that point whatever you're i'm
not saying that maybe you don't have
uh i'm not i'm not maybe brain
development is wrong but
i'm not doubting the sincerity
that's okay this is where i get a little
bit
confused because i always hear in the
red pill oh
you made mistakes like
you can't like did they really learn
from them and at first when i first
heard this i was like
how else are people supposed to learn
other than to make mistakes and then to
learn but what you realize is what he's
questioning is the integrity
like are
are they genuinely like did they
genuinely find god
actually no he said it wasn't but
he's saying the church should question
their integrity a little bit more
because it's
mad convenient all you guys find god
right when you need to find a husband
once again i'm just saying i'm what i'm
saying is that it comes at a convenient
time when we look at uh if you go and
you look at marriage statistics right
now the the average age of first
marriage for certainly women and well
women in the united states is
28.7 and for men it's like 29.8 like
almost 30 years old and it's older than
that in the uk even so i also point this
out but nobody wants to talk about this
because it's not just like you know
sensational but i point out the fact
that
at that stage it also coincides with
exactly what i talk about in the
epiphany phase now i got to settle down
now now i don't have the options that i
used to have
back when i was 23 years old i can't
compete in the sexual marketplace with
my my 33 year old self cannot compete
with my 23 year old self in the sexual
marketplace when it comes to women at
least and that's where people get
emotional because women are like jayla's
still hot
but is jayla as hot as she was at 23.
no
no i mean look it
if you work hard at your fitness you're
gonna be hotter than most people like
the average girl is overweight she's
like 150. now don't give me i'm over 150
but i'm six foot and i still like could
be in better shape to be honest i like
food too much it's bad but
you guys get what i'm saying
like a lot of rolos concepts you have to
watch a lot before you really understand
that is right around the time and again
it's that's the point at which women say
i want to my biological clock is ticking
right
here you don't hear women complain about
men being sort of infantile or wanting
to you know afraid of strong you know
threatened by strong independent women
you don't hear women of 23 saying those
things i did 33 and you hear them at 34
but you don't hear them when women are
in the midst of their peak sexual agency
in their lives so when they get to a
point where all the chips are oh i
actually did too
all the stuff he's saying i definitely
heard that stuff when i was in college
down
that's when it's men aren't measuring up
i can't find an economic no i girls say
that all the time
you're just
you're just too old i'm gonna be honest
the first time i noticed that
i couldn't compete with like the younger
girls was so young
okay so i'll give you i'll give you an
example i i didn't i started college
when i was 17
and
i i had did not talk to boys at all in
high school i was so awkward i still am
but like
i don't know i didn't i got no male
attention in high school at all go to
college you're like flooded i also went
to a school where it was like mostly
mostly female
or mostly male so it was like
they'd say you'd like
like people they call it eta glasses
like you'd get hotter because there's
like no women
um
and then the next year i realized i was
like
even though i went to a new school and i
got humbled because it was like the
opposite ratio but
um
i just noticed like even at the new
school that it was like if you were
fresh like a freshman like they're they
would just get more attention
like that's what and then the guys would
want to like talk to them more than like
the girls that they'd already
like met the year before perfectly
attractive man um and i can't find a guy
who is uh you know right with god or i
can't find a guy who wants to be who
wants to date and marry a single mother
it's not it's not my fault it's not my
decisions it's those guys who won't man
up it's those guys who won't take
responsibility and absolve me of the
consequences of my decisions that i made
that are now coming into effect at 30 33
years old
yeah okay so i i get i completely
understand where you're coming from but
i think you're lumping me into a
category of women i don't exist in i was
complaining about
men not wanting to get married when i
was 21. like i've wanted a stable family
like i said since i was 16. as for
competing in the sexual marketplace
my like i understand i'm older but
that's not my issue right i'm not going
to have a problem there do you
understand that as a single mother
york let's just
oh you see it see her face she's getting
offended she's getting offended
competitiveness maybe i should now i
hate to commodify everything for you
here but
your
your value as a woman is less than
somebody who does not have kids and if
you're looking at 20 you're soon to be
30 years old if you're looking for that
long-term relationship which you've said
you are
looking for a guy who's like at your age
or older the men who will be looking for
what you're looking for aren't looking
for you they're looking for women who
are much younger than you who do not
have kids do you
acknowledge that do you understand that
well you seem to think that every woman
is exactly the same no i think
like yeah if they're gonna find
commonalities for sure
yeah
but i'm not the same kind of person as
the woman you're talking about i don't
have an iq of a hundred i'm not a [ __ ]
i'm fairly attracted but men don't care
about that stuff michaela ah they don't
care
i did a poll okay that said
basically like
like a kid subtracts you by two points
i'd give her like an eight
i like in our society i give her an
eight
but then
she's a six with a kid attractive i
don't think i'm gonna have an issue and
what i did decide obviously this was a
concern of mine right
like clearly single mom that's not like
no one's plan is that right but i
decided that the situation i was in here
no britney renner planned it so
oh wow that doesn't seem like a wise
decision
but uh what i decided from the situation
i was in was you see his face he's like
well
i would rather be by myself and so i
would just wrap my head around being by
myself
and so that wasn't my my concern wasn't
a hypergamy i'm going to go find someone
you know older wiser smarter better
richer
you know and but you want someone that's
a better fit that's what you're looking
for you know it
do that i just figured hey i'll just
hunker down and work at least i'll be
happier by myself
so you have no plans to
find a long-term husband in the future
then no that's what i want i just think
it's gonna be difficult okay do you
realize what statistically speaking here
now i'm just dragging out you know raw
numbers here statistically speaking do
you understand
the odds of you finding that
right now
in today's sexual marketplace
do you know the odds of fighting do you
know do you know the odds of finding
somebody if you have an iq above 115 or
130 as well i know it's yeah it just
gets worse so then single mom age
higher iq yeah it's going to be an issue
and of course that's what i want i told
you you mean just date someone with a
lower iq
yeah it is it is tough but i mean it's
and it only gets and it only gets
tougher the older you get you realize
definitely i would assume i don't think
i don't think
i don't think i'm like being again
your father always said you know to you
have to risk being offensive to like
have critical debates so i'm not trying
to like kick you in the ass no it's okay
this is why you're on here
yeah
so this is why you're on here so my my
point is is that
and when you go i know you're are you
still scheduled to go on impression fit
like later on i think next month yeah
february i think okay so i'm going to
i'm going to prep you for here's here's
your preparation for fresh and fit
because myron's going to bring up the
same exact thing that i'm saying to you
right now which is as a woman gets older
her value declines her value decreases a
woman's primary agency in life is her
sexual marketability that's not personal
value okay so it's very important that
you like as most women conflate sexual
market value with
their personal worth right mother teresa
fantastic human being you know let's
let's make her a saint right her sexual
market value let's just be honest okay
however so there's a def i'm not music
again extreme examples right i'm using
her as an example here to say that
there's a separation between sexual
market value and
personal worth and that's i think is one
of the primary problems that women have
today because they're like you they say
you know what there's uh the incident or
say the enrollment for you know higher
education right now women are enrolling
in record numbers in in college um i
certainly outclassing men at this point
i don't think i'm busy okay but that's
the problem like what
and i relate because i i have always
taken a lot of pride in my work ethic
that's something i really pride myself
on i work hard though not smart that's
that's that's a flaw but
um like that's all my dad always told me
to do is like work hard work hard at
whatever you do work hard work hard and
as a girl like we we want to compete in
certain stuff like i've always wanted to
work hard at sports
i'm in a mail space on youtube i
work hard at this channel
um
i'm not particularly into school like
that so maybe i didn't work that hard at
school but
that's that's the problem is like what
what is the solution do we just not do
any of the things we like to do
i don't know let me know this is any
kind of revelation for anyone here but
also i'm starting to get real tired
this is we're going to end this very
soon
as your father has said they're the lost
boys generation right they are they're
dropping out they have are purposeless
they're not going to college they're not
getting are they getting just like
subsistence level jobs so that they can
sort of you know do what they want to
and they're not have any plans to be a
father no plans to be a
let me tell you the lost boys generation
is very frustrating to date
this is
yeah it's very frustrating to date so
let me tell you guys
i know part of the a lot of the problem
is women but it's also men that like
aren't like they're still like they're
they're not adults you know like they're
like children a lot of the time
respectfully no offense it's just
husband no plans like that old order
kind of 20th century uh married
monogamous ideal is not even if there's
no incentive
for uh certainly this is generation z
and like maybe the latter half of
millennials right now there's no an
incentive for guys to do that so what is
that what happens there's more women
that are enrolled in college right now
higher education they they get more
professional degrees they get going to
the american workplace um
i mean statistically speaking women are
like improving themselves or men are
just kind of like you know and we poke
fun at the guys and we say well they
need to take more responsibility for
themselves and while we're having that
conversation women just like you women
just like the the women who work for
robert kiyosaki who i i work with as
well they're saying the same thing as
you or you will say i think pretty soon
here is i can't find a guy who is my
equal i can't find a guy who has his
[ __ ] together i can't find a guy who is
economically attractive i can't find a
guy but this is the thing this is the
thing
they'll always say oh you can't do
better than your baby daddy but what is
better
like
where were people
like you don't know what traits a person
values you don't know if it's money
alone iq alone it could be something
else it could be like a guy that's
higher
in agreeableness or maybe not
agreeableness that's not a great trait
usually but
enthusiasm i don't know draw like
religion
value like whatever is important to you
so just because you
but but i'm also in the the boat that
you should do everything you can to work
it out with the father of your kids and
it doesn't seem like she did but i don't
know who is you know whatever your
prerequisite is and the reason for that
is because you're very intelligent and
you went to college and you have i don't
know how much money i don't know how
much you're worth but you make a good
chunk of change
so by doing that and by improving
yourself and building yourself up into
who michaela peterson is or you know
whoever you're you know sort of strong
independent alpha female is
um you have less and less opportunity to
get with her who is going to be that
much just even
fractionally above you i actually do
think that she'll find someone because
the thing about being a social media
influencer is that
her pool is going to be different
because all she has so much more
exposure to like
guys of her the caliber she's looking
for in sexual market value because women
conflate sexual market value with
personal worth right now and so for me
to say this and i've said this and it
frustrates the hell out of the women
that i talk to uh who are part of robert
kiyosaki's crew
they're just like you they went to
college in some cases they've got like a
you know at least a four-year degree in
some cases even like you know
post-graduate kind of stuff
and they're making money and they're
like i'm frustrated i can't find the
right guy i can't find anybody right now
or they don't want to have anything to
do with me and it's because they have
built themselves up to what they are
that they become less attractive to the
guys who would want to get with them in
the first place
simply through evolutionary biological
reasons that they don't want to get with
a woman like that that's a problem as i
genuinely enjoy doing so much like i
really enjoy
uh oh [ __ ]
i really there we go i really enjoy like
music and i really enjoy like building
this youtube channel
that
i don't know
i don't think i'd make a very good
housewife i don't think i'm like the
traditional that the manosphere like
idealizes
but in my head i'm like
literally
there's so many people out there
i don't know i guess time will tell you
can let me know in the comments will i
end up alone comment below
don't forget to subscribe guys you
already know if you've watched three
more of my videos you haven't subscribed
with beef beef
okay i'll talk to you later bye